why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so before we get too far into Excalibur
we first need to step back and do a
little bit of a discussion here about
Brian bradock now we're not going to be
going as in depth into our discussion
about Brian bradock as we will with his
video proper due to our uh the fact that
he's part of the human High Council and
our leadup to the Age of Apocalypse
event but Brian bradock was created in
1976 by Chris Claremont and herb trimp
and the reason why is because around
this time Marvel was looking to expand
overseas they were looking to draw in
both European and British readers and
the way for them to do this was to of
course create characters that these
individuals could identify with that
British readers could identify with and
so what they did is they came up with
the idea of Brian bradock now the reason
why this was given to Chris Claremont is
because again in 1975 Chris Claremont
was uncredited with giant size X-Men
issue number one but by 1976
Chris Claremont was considered the
authority the writer for the X-Men the
most popular writer that Marvel had
going at the time and so it made sense
that they would use him as a means to uh
to bring various readers in due to the
reputation that he had and so in 1970
I'm sorry 1987 to 1988 Marvel launched
an event called the fall of mutants now
whether or not Marvel intended to use
the fall of mutants storyline to segue
into bringing Excalibur into the
mainstream to forming the team and then
making it a mainstream team is something
we don't really know all we know is that
with the end of the fall of mutant
storyline it was perceived that most of
the X-Men had been killed now we know
that those X-Men didn't actually die
they were simply just non-observable
except by looking at them with a with
your physical eyes but uh for most of
the world it was perceived that these
X-Men had been killed and so in 1988
Marvel launched the one shot called
Excalibur the sword is drawn and what
this did is it gave us an explanation of
to how it was that the Excalibur team
had come to together as to how it was
this Excalibur team had formed and again
of the original X-Men or I guess the
X-Men team that was formed the only
individuals who were left for the most
part were Kitty pride and Nightcrawler
and they were left here due to their own
uh various circumstances their own
events that uh left them out of being
part of the conflict that had led to the
presumed destruction of the uh of the
X-Men and what we see with this story as
we begin to pick up is that we join
Kitty pride in some kind of a nightmare
and kitty Pride as she's going through
through this appears to be on maybe some
kind of a movie set on some kind of a
situation where Charles Xavier is the
director and the X-Men appear to be uh
actors but Kitty pride has a Bittersweet
feeling about this for her it's good to
see that the X-Men are alive but she
also has the feeling that something's
not quite right here in addition we're
given a few Clues to indicate that this
may in fact be the reality the universe
of Mojo now Mojo again is a character
we've never touched on and we may not
touch on Mojo I'm not 100% sure about
that yet but Mojo had a place called
Mojo world and it's where individuals
were forced to act out uh I guess a form
of entertainment for The Observers of
Mojo's television show and so what Mojo
did is had previously been uh capturing
the X-Men and forcing them into this
role and as Kitty pride is going through
and speaking with uh various X-Men she's
of course uh glad to see that Betsy
bradick that the twin sister of Brian
bradock psylock is alive but for her
things are very strange because psylock
doesn't have any eyes when the eyes are
installed in into her head this is
horrifying to uh to Kitty pride in
addition Kitty Pride also encounters
Rogue she encounters storm but none of
them are identifying with her the way
that they would in the re in normal
reality in normal continuity they're
referring to her as somebody that's may
be less than that she's unprofessional
that she doesn't know how to conduct
herself in these situations and for the
most part it appears as though this is
the I guess maybe the subconscious uh
manifestation of the X-Men in the mind
of kitty pride in terms of how kitty
Pride sees herself in relation to the
X-Men that Charles Xavier as the
Director of this movie Set is the one
that's leading the show and that the
X-Men are simply carrying out the roles
that have been established for them by
Charles Xavier but what we see is that
Rachel Summers appears to Kitty pride in
presumably this dream and what Rachel
Summers tells us is that this may not
actually be a dream that kitty Pride may
very well be looking into an alternate
reality looking into a universe where
this is how the X-Men exists they exist
as movie stars in some kind of a
perverse perverse film that's being
headed up by Charles Xavier in addition
what Rachel Summers also says is that
this may not be a reality that it may
not be some kind of alternate form May
simply be that somebody's tapped into
her mind and they have uh perverted her
perception of the X-Men that this is
possible if somebody's able to enter her
mind which of course is something that
we are aware as being something capable
when we looked at the days of future
past but before Rachel Summers can
explain too much further Charles Xavier
takes notice of her and tells her she's
not supposed to be here that she had
abandoned the X-Men that she had her
chance at being part of the X-Men but
when they needed her most that she had
ran out on them and so the X-Men began
to bind Rachel Summers with chains to
keep her from escaping but what Katy
pride is able to do is to physically
touch Rachel Summers and allow Rachel
Summers to face through her chains
thereby escaping the uh the capture of
um of these various X-Men and again this
appears to be some kind of a dream here
and Rachel Summers says that she may be
seeing Kitty Pride again but we don't
really know what to make of this again
this is a very strange set of
circumstances a very weird uh I guess
situation that's being given to us in
addition as the X-Men begin to round on
uh Kitty Pride due to Rachel Summer's
Escape we see that uh the X-Men begin to
change they begin to take on a different
form and when they do they turn into War
Wolves now War Wolves were used by Mojo
to capture and to hold people within
Mojo world and so it tells us that this
may be the case it may be that this is
Mojo world we don't really know what's
going on here all we know is that kitty
Pride wakes up from this presumed dream
and when she does we realize that she's
actually at M Island and when she goes
out to regain her bearings to uh regas
or I guess regrasp what it is that's
going on that in the sunset she or I
guess in the sunrise she sees the form
of the Phoenix which tells us that you
know maybe this isn't a dream that maybe
this was real that she had glimpsed into
a reality that we're not really given a
definitive answer here from this point
we switch to a woman named Megan and
Megan is the uh the counterpart the
romantic interest of Brian bradock and
Megan of course as a shape shifter is
spending times time with dolphins and
when she looks to the sunrise she sees
of course the uh the Phoenix Force which
tells us that this may very well be a
real thing that since Megan can see it
alongside uh Kitty Pride that this isn't
simply Just an Illusion in the mind of
Katy pride and as Megan travels back to
the lighthouse the headquarters of Brian
bradock she sees that the interior of
the lighthouse is completely disheveled
that the entire area appears to have
been torn up but there are also remnants
of various items belonging to psylock or
perhaps autographs different things like
that what we also see is that Megan is
uh observing a news broadcast telling us
that psylock along with uh the other
X-Men had been killed in Dallas which of
course was something that Megan was
unaware of and so once she begins to put
two and two together she travels to the
top of the lighthouse to visit Brian
bradick and when she does she sees that
Brian bradick is in a drunken state that
he's very angry and he's very distressed
and he's grieving over the loss of his
twin sister psylock and while she tries
to comfort Brian bradock while she tries
to tell him that there was really
nothing he could have done they were
half a world away there was no possible
way for him to know that psylock was in
danger Brian bradock doesn't want to
hear it and so what he does is he lashes
out at Megan he tells her that that she
doesn't really have anyone besides
herself she doesn't know what it's like
to lose someone and so he sends her away
from this point we transitioned to
Nightcrawler back on M island in the
gymnasium and Nightcrawler is of course
Rec ing from his previous bout with uh
his coma and the uh the mutant crossover
event the mutant Massacre event and so
for the most part this is the reason why
he wasn't actually with the X-Men when
they had presumably been killed he was
simply just unconscious and there was
nothing he could have done and so he's
going about trying to rehon his skills
trying to make sure that he's still up
to par with his abilities and his
ability to fight in overwhelming odds
and as he's going through this process
he's joined by Kitty Pride but almost
immediately after Kitty Pride arrives
she gets gets angry at uh at
Nightcrawler and the reason why is
because it seems as though Nightcrawler
had set this conflict up this training
session up to where it would have been
impossible for him to actually win that
he most likely would have been killed in
the process and kitty Pride rationalizes
here that perhaps Nightcrawler has some
sort of guilt that he feels as though he
should have been fighting alongside the
X-Men that maybe he could have helped
some of them survive or even if the if
he couldn't he could have died bravely
he could have died fighting alongside
his his friends and comrades now night
crawler doesn't actually expand on this
he doesn't give her an answer to her
speculation but what he does tell her is
that when he woke up or I guess when he
uh woke up from his coma he realized
everything that had taken place that he
realized as though perhaps he had messed
up that perhaps he could have done
something different that would allowed
him to uh to fight by fight beside the
X-Men but what he also says is that he
had a dream that the dream he had had
the night before was very similar in
fact almost identical to the dream that
kitty Pride had but instead of kitty
Pride being the one to counter the X-Men
to uh free Rachel Summers instead it was
Nightcrawler and so Kitty Pride takes
this as perhaps some kind of a sign and
indeed what this tells us is that
perhaps if Rachel Summers is the one
constant in this situation that maybe
Rachel had reached out telepathically to
both uh to both Nightcrawler and kitty
pride in an effort to help her escape
this isn't something that we know for
sure but when they travel back to the
residents when they travel back inside
they're encountered by somebody named
gate Crasher and gate Crasher is part of
an inter dimensional Bounty Hunter group
named techet now as we get into Brian
bradock later on we'll discuss more of
these interdimensional things especially
when we get into uh into the Captain
Britain Corps but what gay Crasher says
is that she's been sent here for the
sole purpose of capturing someone of a
of grabbing someone and taking her back
for the purpose of uh of whatever orders
had been given to them and at first we
don't really know what it is that's
going on here we don't realize uh you
know who it is that gate Crasher and the
TechNet are supposed to be capturing and
before gate Crasher can expand any
further the team is joined by uh by
Megan and Megan of course is there to
one speak with night crawler and kitty
bride about what's going on but too to
assist them in helping to defeat the
forces of TechNet once she realizes that
TechNet is there and so before gate
Crasher is able to perform whatever
action it is that she needs to perform
she tells Megan Nightcrawler and kitty
Pride why it is that they're there and
what she tells them is that they were
sent by saturnine and saturnine is
omniversal magistri she exists for the
purpose of ensuring that the universes
all the realities that currently exist
maintain the evolutionary uh I guess
push that's going to keep them up keep
them current with all the other
universes she's very similar in terms of
her role with the Living Tribunal the
only difference here is one she doesn't
possess near the power that the Living
Tribunal has but two she isn't really
there to make sure that order exists in
the universe she's there to simply just
make sure that all the universes are
progressing the way that's supposed to
in terms of their evolution in addition
saturnine says that the whole reason why
techet is there is because they're
supposed to capture Rachel Summers that
Rachel Summers perhaps has done
something that she is somehow not
supposed to be there and we know that
she's not because she's part of the uh
Days of Future Past storyline she's the
time displaced Rachel Summers from the
days of future past and so it makes
sense that there would have been some
kind of a consequence for her being in
this reality but what uh what what gay
Crasher says is that her responsibility
here is to simply just capture Rachel
Summers that she doesn't know exactly
what Saturn's rationale is behind
capturing Rachel Summers she doesn't
really know know what the basis is and
for her it doesn't matter her job is to
simply just capture Rachel Summers and
take her back for the request of
saturnine and so we see that the rest of
the forces of the techet arrive and they
begin to engage in combat with
Nightcrawler Megan and kitty Pride now
as these individuals are combating
TechNet we eventually see that one of
the members of techet named bodybag who
is presumably able to capture people and
hold them in in stasis is able to
capture Megan and kitty Pride leaving
Nightcrawler the only person left and of
course he teleports out of there from
here we transition to Rachel Summers who
is apparently falling out maybe falling
out of the sky we're not really sure but
she lands inside of a building and when
she does we get this really cool
throwback to maybe this uh Jasper's warp
mad Jim Jasper's kind of situation where
we see all these strange and cooky
things going on and seems as though
perhaps we're joining her in this weird
reality in which she was in before we
see of course individuals dressed up as
various Marvel characters somebody
dressed up as Thor and so on and so
forth but what we learn as time
progresses is that in fact she's not
actually in an alternate reality that
she is in the main Earth 616 reality and
then she's joined by the werewolves who
of course are pursuing her to try to
capture her and so what this tells us is
that what had happened is apparently
Rachel Summers had been trapped in an
alternate reality and when she was she
had used her mind to reach out to
Nightcrawler and kitty Pride to help her
escape and in their unconscious minds
they used their abilities to help her
Escape her binds and in turn she was
able to somehow leap away from this
reality and travel back to the main
Earth 616 reality we also see her trying
to use her psychic powers on the
werewolves but it's simply just not
working they are able to uh to overcome
her abilities and so she's simply able
to just jump away at this point she
takes off of the building which of
course tells us that she's back in the
earth 616 universe and uh she's within
London proper and so as she begins to
make her way through she tries to escape
we see that she's observed by the
TechNet and the TechNet are simply
looking at her and and monitoring her so
that they can somehow try to find a way
to capture her without drawing too much
attention to themselves at this point we
transitioned back to the lighthouse the
residence of Brian brck with
Nightcrawler and what Nightcrawler does
is he has uh taken Brian brck who
apparently is in a drunken State who is
totally unconscious and throws him into
the water and what he tells us is that
if Brian bradick resurfaces he'll be all
the better for it he'll be totally uh
sober he'll be able to regain his
bearings but if he's not if what he ends
up uh what ends up happening to him is
that he drowns there'll be no real loss
here and the reason why is because for
Nightcrawler a drunk and useless
superhero is of no real value to anyone
and so we see that of course Brian
bradock is able to resurface he's able
to regain his composure and when he does
while he does have a hangover he joins
Nightcrawler as the two of them have a
cup of coffee for Nightcrawler to
explain to Brian bradock what it is is
going on here and what the necessity is
for him to uh I guess to regain his
position as part of the uh of the
British superhero universe and what
Nightcrawler tells Brian bradock here is
that Brian bradock is not the only one
who's grieving that everybody's
struggling here that psylock was not the
only person to die that all the X-Men
are dead that for Nightcrawler he feels
as though he wasn't a true X-Men that if
he was if he really was an X-Man proper
that he would have died alongside his
fellow X-Men that he would have
struggled alongside them but instead he
was unconscious there was really nothing
that he could have done to try to save
their lives and so from here we
transition to a Nightcrawler leaving
Brian branck to his thoughts leaving him
to uh to more or less think about what
it is that's gone on here as
Nightcrawler says that he's going to try
to go about the role of being a
superhero once more from here we
transition back to Rachel Summers as
she's making her way through London
and what Rachel Summers does is she
comes across a window with various
Arthurian items inside one of which is
of course The Sword and the stone
Excalibur but before she's able to uh
delve too much further into this and
she's thinking slightly to herself she
she's encountered by the TechNet and of
course one of the members of TechNet
body bag immediately grabs Rachel
Summers and tries to imprison her which
of course he's successful in doing and
so at this point they've gained their
target technut successfully has achieved
their task in capturing Rachel Summers
and so they use uh they use this this
time to try to attempt to escape to try
to uh find a way to get away but before
they're able to they're encountered by
the werewolves now TechNet and the and
the werewolves put up a good fight
against one another and there are some
members that are lost on both sides but
for the most part tech neck comes out on
top on this particular conflict but what
we also see is that Nightcrawler appears
and Nightcrawler uses this time to
overpower bodybag and to free Rachel
Summers Kitty pride and Megan now Rachel
summer is because she had been so
recently captured to still conscious and
Nightcrawler speculates that perhaps
body bag uses some kind of an enzyme or
some kind of a chemical to to I guess
consciously subdue the uh the minds of
anybody that he captures telling us why
it is that both Kitty pride and Megan
are completely unconscious but what we
also see is that as Nightcrawler is
about to be overtaken by one of the
werewolves and presumably killed that
Brian bradock appears carrying or I
guess uh establishing himself under the
mantle of C Captain Britain and with
Captain Britain Nightcrawler Rachel
Summers fighting together they're able
to overpower uh the techet they're able
to escape and when they do they uh more
or less come under the guise of creating
themselves or establishing themselves as
a superhero group of calling themselves
Excalibur and the reason why they had
chosen the name Excalibur was more or
less from the idea of Rachel Summers who
had looked at Excalibur who had seen an
Excalibur as this indestructible thing
as this rigid sword in a stone to where
almost no one was able to uh to more or
less yank it out no one was able to uh
to yank it away from its foundation and
this is more or less her just trying to
use a metaphor of sorts to establish
them as a real team to establish them as
a real basis but what we'll see is that
as time progresses with uh the Excalibur
Comics as things begin to move forward
Excalibur runs for about 10 years it
runs for about 125 issues and this is
where Excalibur really began to break
away really began to establish itself as
a a different form from what we had seen
with Uncanny X-Men parallel to the time
that Excalibur was running in Marvel
Comics we of course had The Uncanny
X-Men series which was being written by
Chris Claremont but The Uncanny X-Men
series were very dark they were very
serious they were these very gritty
stories involving the X-Men characters
and looking Beyond them and their
superpowers and focusing on on the
perception of them or the actuality of
them as characters with Excalibur we
didn't see that Excalibur gave us uh
conflicts with various X-Men villains
like uh like Juggernaut but with
Excalibur for the most part the stories
were light-hearted the stories were very
fun the stories were very interesting
but what we'll see as time progresses is
that over the course of this 10-year run
things will begin to change and the
stories will begin to move away from
being light-hearted to becoming darker
ultimately leading to the cancellation
of Excalibur volume 1 with issue number
[Music]
so as the Excalibur Comics started off
light-hearted they started off as a
great Breakaway from the monotony of
what it was that made the X-Men story so
dark we eventually began to see a
problem with the Excalibur comics and
that problem was the X-Men teams the
Xmen Comics were wildly successful in
the late 80s going going into the early
90s and so there really wasn't much of a
chance for Excalibur to succeed here
because a lot of people were branching
out and they were looking at Excalibur
but when they saw Excalibur they didn't
see what it was that they liked in the
X-Men comics and so the Excalibur sales
began to dwindle this was compounded by
the fact that the creative team behind
Excalibur Chris claremon and Alan Davis
had left in 1990 and 1991 and so the
original basis behind the team's
formation was no longer effective and
Excalibur proper and so by this point we
saw various people taking up the roles
of Excalibur we saw various people
coming in and riding for Excalibur and
the problem here was that they weren't
able to maintain the element of what it
was that had initially made Excalibur
successful and so what Marvel started to
do is they started to shape the stories
they started to change the stories that
Excalibur became very dark and very
serious the same way that the X-Men had
and so with this people saw Excalibur
and the question was why buy Excalibur
Comics if I'm going to see the same
thing that I see with the X-Men comics
and so this is why I say Excalibur never
really had a chance Excalibur never had
the opportunity to really be as
successful as the X-Men were and so with
is number 125 in 1998 Marvel cancelled
Excalibur volume 1 now Marvel re brought
I guess brought the series back they
rebooted it in Excalibur Volume 2 in
2001 but this was just a 4issue limited
series and we saw of course a change in
a lineup we saw the return of psylock we
saw Black Knight Serb Ser Benedict and
and various other people but what Marvel
was looking to do here is they were more
or less testing the waters they were
asking the question what would happen if
we reintroduce Excalibur would it be
receptive the 4issue limmited series was
relatively popular but it wasn't nearly
as popular as of course the previous run
of Excalibur comics and this is what we
saw over the years in 2004 after Grant
Morrison's run of uh of the X-Men and we
saw of course um the destruction of
josha at the hands of Cassandra Nova
Marvel brought Excalibur back again and
this version of Excalibur was less
popular than the one before it with new
Excalibur between 2005 and 2007 we saw
the same thing the team just became less
and less popular or time progressed
where eventually no one really cared
about Excalibur that much because there
wasn't much going on here in terms of
the stories no one could really identify
with Excalibur they really couldn't get
into the stories of Excalibur and So
eventually Marvel dropped the series
entirely now what Marvel's going to
actually do going into the future with
Excalibur is something we don't know we
don't know if it'll ever actually come
back we don't know if maybe Excalibur
will be gone forever we have no real
idea of what'll take place here but for
the most part I think that Marvel's
going to look at their major 2015 Summer
Event the incursions and all these
things that are going on and they may
look at this as an opportunity to bring
back Excalibur to bring back the stories
that had made them popular alongside the
characters with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys later
[Music]
peace
oh